well that's uh that's a hell of a way to
make a first impression black mirror
time again I got through all of season
four I enjoyed it I'm now going all the
way back to the beginning working my way
up to where I started so I've got
seasons one two three to get through so
let's start with season 1 episode 1 the
national anthem and folks I gotta tell
you something I think I might be sick
like really sick
cuz I laughed I laughed a lot like
pretty much the Oh spoilers just so you
know that episode is almost eight almost
seven years old all right you just
spoilers so pretty much as soon as they
mention the pig I burst out laughing and
I laughed really hard for a while now I
will grant at least to a certain extent
that is because of what has actually
happened since then and David Cameron
and oh my god how bizarre is it that
that that scandal happened four years
later that must have been so surreal and
I obviously I mean I was aware of it but
I didn't closely follow it or anything
but I can only imagine the sheer volume
of black mirror references the high
water for that episode we aired a whole
bunch during that time oh I hope so
somebody from the UK tell me if that
happened but in any case so that that
may have upped the humor value of this
whole thing for more than it was worth I
will grant that but I can't put myself
into the mindset of somebody who didn't
know that that happened later on that's
what I know that's what I that's the
baggage I come to this with so yeah it
did it did make it pretty funny I do
think though that there's a fair amount
of darkly humorous moments spread
throughout the thing that aren't
be funny because of that sort of weird
meta coincidence of life so like the the
stuff with the reporter and she gets
information out of the out of the guy in
the government I that was funny it was
pragmatic overworked you know things
like that or the I love that one that
when it happens they just show this you
know they pan across initially in the
pub and then also they show other people
reacting to it and you know some people
cover their mouth some people were kind
of like had weird little grins like oh
my god and some people just stared
something almost nobody looked away
though which I think it was interesting
and probably pretty accurate to life or
you know just the part where this woman
tries to turn it off and the guy's like
oh don't which is like he's been going
for almost an hour like oh god and again
I laughed so and here's the thing I do
think that the setup the premise Prime
Minister not eat not even my almost a
black male not black no coerced by
terrorists to have sex with a pig on
national television that that does that
sounds like a joke setup that's not you
know that that sounds like it belongs in
like one of the early scary movie films
you know the r-rated super raunchy look
how edgy we are kind of comedies that I
tend to hate actually if I'm being
completely honest but it feels like it's
pulled out of something like that so to
take that set up and do it completely
dead serious and to have it work I mean
I was gonna say have it not be laughable
but I was laughing but I wasn't laughing
in it this is so stupid way I was
laughing and I can't believe they
actually made this way and I I really
got a commend their ability to lock down
this insanity and make it work because I
get
that that premise you hear it it sounds
like a joke
and that they did it straight and a lot
of that I mean a lot of that goes to the
director and then the method of filming
and it feels very it feels like a mix of
political drama and espionage which
effectively it is the cast also does a
really great job of selling it I can
only imagine some of the faces on some
of these casts looking over the script
going wait you you want me to play this
straight okay so I mean also I did
there's a lot of actors that I
recognized which for me is always fun I
get to go oh that guy's from Game of
Thrones I saw her on Doctor Who that
guy's in James Bond and I enjoy that and
I can bring things up a little bit for
me and I don't always get that with
British films because or British TV
shows more specifically I tend to not
get it too much but because I well I
enjoyed British stuff I don't watch I
got ton of it so I don't recognize you
know as much as I would expect
you know natives to the country to
direct nice so when I do catch catch
faces it's it's always nice that I get
from that so that that's pretty cool the
the technology factoring in on it was it
was it was definitely there because it
was the technology of social media and
how fast things spread and how
irrelevant the old methods of keeping a
lid on it are you know we don't have an
equivalent in the US but in the you know
the UK they have d notice and they have
you know these ways to for the
government to try and clamp down on on
the news media and it doesn't matter
once it's on the internet it's there
everybody can see it and you know so
okay so you stopped the British news
from running it but CNN will run it
al-jazeera will run it and they and it's
all over Twitter so that way that the
technology factored in again fits black
mayor but it wasn't it was way less
front and center they really zeroed in
on the on the drama of this guy trying
to decide
whether or not he's gonna do this thing
and then the impact of his decision to
do it and I think that more than
anything else those closing notes that
actually happened during the ending
credits are what really make this
episode and they are what make it black
mirror at least for me and for my
understanding what the show is because
you get initially you know this whole
thing of yo it's a year later his poll
numbers are actually up his career is
unaffected and you kind of go a shrug
and go man you know public sure is
fickle aren't they funny that didn't
even stick didn't matter and then he
goes inside 10 Downing Street with his
wife and as soon as they're out of the
public eye she won't even look at him
won't talk to him won't acknowledge him
nothing and it's this quiet moment
that's done so quickly and so simply and
not even really lingered on but it is
given prominence simply by being the
last thing that is shown in the episode
and it's a wonderful contrast to what
immediately came before because okay so
you know something something you did
went viral but you know the world cares
for a day a year later nobody cares
nobody remembers well not in the social
media sphere at any rate the people in
your life the people you love the people
you interact with a know day to day they
do care and they're not so fickle and
they don't forget and they may not be
able to overlook the pain the
humiliation that they feel over
something you did and you know the the
impact of your on your digital profile
and your digital footprint on the world
is lingering it's intense but short but
the impact on the real connections in
your life they are they are lasting
and though and that impact is what you
actually truly have to live with not the
much showy or impact of you know a big
splashy a this thing happened now is
trending on Twitter kind of thing and
that that feels very black mirror
because that it is actually fairly
depressing but in this case I think a
bit more subtly than in the episodes at
least that I've seen so far because
while it is a somber note for the whole
thing to end on the depth of how
depressing it actually is you have to
think about it
you need to stop and go wait a minute
and then the the depth of that starts to
weigh on you and that the Hat is very
black mirror and like I said it's a lot
subtler which is not necessarily a
better or worse thing I one of the
things I like about this show is that I
feel like it adjusts the method of
delivering its point its theme its final
you know note to end on differently
largely depending on what works best for
the story cuz some stories have points
or themes that you want to sort of sneak
in and around and sort of just get them
there and let people discover them in
other ones the point is made better by
beating them in the face with it
so I like that this show that the show
really is able to adjust itself from
episode to episode story to story and
just make little changes and the way
that it approaches things whether it's
the technology whether it's how hard it
hits the more depressing notes of the
themes of things or how you know maybe
those things are more background maybe
they're front and center and that it as
much as it fits this mold of here's how
technology factors into the story here's
the weird depressing craziness that that
you have to think about within those
parameters that it is
malleable and shifts and I it always
feels like those shifts are made and
determined by what is the best way to
tell this story and that's just good
writing and good directing and good
acting and just good I mean that's just
good television and yeah this this thing
I can I can only imagine what it's like
seeing this for the first time that it
aired I mean what up what a first
impression what a way to just come in
and say if you can't handle this don't
stick around because that's what we're
dealing with here but I did laugh I did
laugh a lot I might need help but have
you seen this I assume so cuz like it
said talk spoilers so what were your
thoughts on the national anthem whatever
they are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it tell me
exactly how thick you think I am or if
you share my sickness and then you know
do all the things the the likes and the
subscribes and I'm on Twitter I got a
podcast that I got a patreon if you're
feeling generous links for all that
stuff is down below and until next time
this council is adjourned
and I would like you know - for the
record I made it this entire recording
but a single this little piggy joke
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]